رئيس تويتر السابق يقرب الذنب كل الغلط
غلط فيه هو حمى كاس العالم تصيب تك توك
بمشاهدات ملياريه وجوجل في ضيافه تفاعلكم
الاستعراض ملخص 20 22 اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تويتر ورئيس واخبارهم واليوم
الاخبار مو عن الرئيس الحالي اهل مصر لا
خبر اليوم عن الرئيس السابق جاك دورسي
اللي من بعد سلسله من خمسه حلقات من
الفضائح واللي كشفها الماسك عن اداره
تويتر السابقه
وفسادها وسماحها للسياسه بالضغط على
الشركه وتدخلها في امور كثيره واللي اخر
حلقاتها كانت عن الاشياء اللي صارت في
الخفاء لحظر حساب ترامب من بعد كل هذا خرج
جاك دورسي عن صمته وطلع وعلقلق وكتب صراحه
بيان طويل وحقيقه لو في عنوان واحد نلخص
فيه البيان راح يكون كان هذا خطا بالكامل
دوسي شال المسؤوليه واقر بذنبه ولكن وضح
وكمان فسر ايش قصده بهذا الكلام وايش كان
خطاوه اللي قالوا دوسي انه غلط انه استسلم
للضغوط خاصه من بعد ما ناشط معين اشترى
اسهم في الشركه لكنه بيقول انه استسلم وما
قاوم لانه كان فاقد للامل تماما جاك دوسي
في المنشور الطويل ما ذكر اسم المستثمر
الناشط اللي قصده عنه لكن كل الترجيحات
بتقول انه المقصود بشركه اليه مانجمنت
بقياده جيسيكون اللي اشترى فيه 20 20
الحصه الاكبر من تويتر
387 مليون دولار وقال انه من وقتها وهو
بدا يخطط لمغادره الشركه واصلا كان في
كلام انه المستثمرين الجدد هذول ما كانوا
حابينوا وكانوا بيطفشوا وجعك انسحب بعدها
من تويتر
جاء كمان قال انه اكبر اخطاء وكان انه
خلال الفتره اللي كان بيخطط فيها للمغادره
استمر في الاستثمار في بناء ادوات للتحكم
في حوارات الناس على تويتر بدلا من بناء
ادوات تعطي الناس القدره على التحكم في
حواراتهم بانفسهم
فاز المنتخب الارجنتيني على كرواتيا وتاهل
لنهائي كاس العالم وبعد اقل من اربع ساعات
بس انطلق المواجهه اللي راح اتحدث
المنافسه الثانيه على اللقب بين منتخبين
المغرب وفرنسا واذا بتتفرجوا على الاعاده
في المباراه في الغالب خلصت
النتيجه كاس العالم خلاص بيخلص والاحد
حسين لاعبه المباراه
وكان حديث كل الجلسات خلال الشهر الماضي
ومن النشاط التواصل طبعا ما كانت استثناء
ابدا لكن الملاحظه بقوه في هذا المونديال
انه حمى كاس العالم اصابته او اصابت عفوا
تيك توك بعنف وقوه اكثر من غيره من
المنصات وفيها هاشتاجات معينه شفنا عليها
مشاركه 100%
مثلا مقاطع المباريات لردات فعل لنكت
الفريق لتحليل المحتوى تنوع صراحه لك لكن
بقيه كاس العالم الموضوع الاسخر على التيك
توك الشهر الماضي
ونبقى مع اخبار تيك توك ومفاجاه بواجها في
امريكا في مجموعه مشرعين امريكيه من
الحسبه الديمقراطي والجمهوري قدموا مشروع
قانون لحضرتك الصيني بسبب مخاوف على الامن
القومي من التجسس واستنكار ما يقدم من
محتوى عليه والتشريع بيحضر التعامل مع اي
شركه التواصل في الصين وروسيا او تخضع
للنفوذ البيان حتى وصف ابقاء تيك توك بانه
بيشبه السماح للاتحاد السوفيتي زمان بشراء
نيويورك
في وقت فرضت في عدد من الولايات الامريكيه
قيود على استخدام تيك توك على الاجهزه
الالكترونيه الحكومه ومنها تحديدا سبع
ولايات مثل سوف
ببيان منع فيه استخدام الاجهزه
الالكترونيه الحكوميه لتطبيق تيك توك ومثل
وشايفين في البيان نبدا بعدد مستخدمين تيك
توك في امريكا واللي بيبلغ 100 مليون
مستخدم يعني عدد صراحه مو قليل اصلا
دونالد ترامب حاول في 2020 انه يحضر تيك
توك لكن خسر سلسله معارك قضائيه يعني
المحاولات هذه مو جديده في الطرف الاخر
كان نرد على كل هذه الاخبار من شركه تيك
توك انه مثيره هذه الامور كلها مثيره
للقلق ووصفت المحاولات بانها مدفوعه
السياسيه ولن تعود بالنفع على الامن
القومي
وفي مستجدات قضيه بلوجر المصريه هدير عاطف
اللي متابعينها معاكم من كذا يوم ولانقبض
عليها وعلى طليقها واخته وزوجها بتهمه
النصب والاحتيال وتحقق معاهم كلهم في
الاول كان قبض على هدير واخت طليقها
وزوجها وبعدين ومن 24 ساعه تقريبا او اكثر
شويه قبض على طليقهم وبدات تحقيق معاهم
جميعا بشكل مبدئي الجديد اليوم انه قاضي
المعارضات في التجمع الخامس امر بتجديد
حبس المتهمين الاربعه 15 يوم على ذمه
التحقيقات محامي هدير كان ظهر معنا امس
مشاهدينا واكد روايه اهلها
بالروايه لاهلها بيقولوها من اول يوم وهي
انه هدير ما كانت تعرف شيء عن شغل زوجها
سبب الطلاق كان اكتشافها انهم اعماله فيها
شيء مشبوه طيب تسريحات خاصه لنا اليوم
محامي هدير الاستاذ محمود السمري قال انه
طليقها خلال التحقيق مع اعترف بارتكاب
الجريمه ونفاصلت هدير اشتراكها باللقاء
مؤكد انه ما كانت تعرف شيء عن اللي بيصير
ابدا احنا بناكد طبعا مشاهدينا انه هذا
الكلام بحسب محامي هدير لكن بيان رسمي
بمضمون التحقيقات ما صدر لسه لكن احنا
طبعا متابعين القضيه معكم
في نادي سويسري لكره القدم
حب انه يطفي لمسه فنيه على الكل بهالصوره
في تغيير ملابس اللاعبين ويزينها وما
يتركها ممله
فنانتين تشكيليتين وكلهم بهذه المهمه
الفنانين يعني خلينا نقول لهم هم من
المعروفين بانهم يعني
بيقدم وفن تقدم ومختلف لكن الحقيقه يا
ريتهم
ولا تعبوا حالهم وخلوا الجدران فاضيه كان
اكرم لهم ولا كان جابوني انا ارسم عليها
وانا متاكد انه معك كل ضعفي في الرسم راح
يكون رسمه احسن لانه اللي راح تشوفوه
امامكم الان هو النتيجه النهائيه طب يعني
انتم شايفين الان هل يعقل يعني هل هذا
الكلام معقول
الكارثه الكبرى مو هنا بس العمل الفني
اللي شفتوه اندفع فيه للفنانتين 28000
دولار او لا لا دولار ايه 28,000 يورو
متخيلين يعني ارجع بالله يوروني العمل على
الفني عن قرب ثاني متخيلين انه انتم هذا
الفن اندفع في قدرنا نسميه فن يعني اندفع
في 28,000 يورو عموما اللاعبين طردوا
واحتجوا حتى واحد منهم اول ما دخل الغرفه
انفجعوا وفكر انه في ناس اقتحامه المكان
وخربوه بصراحه ما ينلام ولما الصور انتشرت
اون لاين الناس كمان علقت واحتجت وسخرت
بصراحه ووصف العمل الفني بخربش الاطفال
اعتقد برده كمان هذا الوصف يعني صراحه في
ظل يخرب الاطفال كمان
اهلا من جديد من بدايه الشهر واحنا
بنستعرض معاكم ملخصات وحصاد من السنه مع
اقترابها من النهايه وفقرتنا الجايه من
هذا النوع ونجمعها اليوم جوجل المحرك
البحث الاول في العالم واللي يعني اسمه
تحول حتى لفعل اسر جوجل او بمثابه مرادف
لكلمه بحث او ابحث جوجل مع اقتراب السنه
من نهايتها نشرت فيديو في ابرز ما بحث عن
الناس
اعملي لايكن هاعمل هازنجاوا كده
على جوجل جمل
العفويه والعثور على الشغف وبالنسبه
للكلمات في عالميا لعبه ورد الجديده كانت
في المركز الاول الاسماء مباريات مهمه في
بطوله كريكيت كانوا ايضا في راس القائمه
هذه اللعبه الشهيره جدا في بريطانيا
والهند والاسيويه اخرى عديده اوكرانيا
والملكه اليزابيكانو وكمان في راس القائمه
لكن لو حبينا نفصل اكثر في النتائج ونمسك
مثلا الاخبار راح نلاقيه اوكرانيا في
المرتبه الاولى رحيل الملك في المرتبه
الثانيه نتائج الانتخابات في المرتبه
الثالثه المرتبه الرابعه للي نصيب
الامريكي الشهير باور بول والخامسه عندنا
الجدري القرده اما بالنسبه للمشاهير في
التاليه اسمائهم كانوا اكثر من بحث عنهم
الناس على جوجل طبعا جوني داب في المرتبه
الاولى وفي المرتبه الثالثه طريقته بسبب
المحاكمه الشهيره بينهم في قضيه التشهير
اللي سابعها العالم كله واللي كسبها جوني
ديب في المرتبه الثانيه عندنا ويل سميث في
المرتبه الخامسه كريس روك والسبب طبعا
الصفحه الشهير اللي اكلها كريس من ولفي
حفل الاوسكار اما في المرتبه الرابعه فكان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمر بالنسبه للرياضيين
في اول ثلاث مراتب كان في نوفاكوفيتش
ورافاييل نزال وسيرينا وليامز جدا صراحه
انه الثلاثه لاعبين تنس لانه يعني صحيح هم
من اشهر لاعبين العالم لكن اللعبه النخويه
نوعا مقارنه يعني لعبه كره القدم اما
بالنسبه للوفيات فاكثر الراحلين الى الناس
كانت مهتمه فيهم على جوجل في 20 22 كانوا
او مثل ما هو متوقع في المرتبه الاولى
اللي رحلت عن 97 السنه بعد 70 سنه حكم في
المرتبه الثانيه الممثله باتي وايت اللي
رحلت في 31 ديسمبر 20 21 عن 99 عاما وراها
ان هيف اللي قضت في حادث سير كانت سارقه
فيه واتضح انها كانت تحت تاثير مخدرات وهي
بتسوق وبعدها بوب ساقط نجم في الهاوس اللي
توفى بشكل مفاجئ في نوم وفي يناير والفنان
اللي توفي من كم اسبوع وهو شقيق النجم
فرقه
من النتائج العالميه الى النتائج المحليه
خلونا نبدا سوا ونشوف اكثر كلمات انا
عملنها في جوجل في السعوديه ومصر في 20 22
[موسيقى]
اما بالنسبه للشخصيات في اكثر من تصدر
وجوجل في السعوديه ومصر هم هذه القائمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واخيرا تعال نروح عالم الموسيقى ونشوف
اكثر الاغاني الي اتصدرت جوجل هذه السنه
[موسيقى]
نفسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وينضم لنا في الاستوديو رئيس تسويق
المنتجات الاستهلاكيه في جوجل للشرق
الاوسط والشمال افريقيا نجيب جرار اهلا
فيك معنا نجيب
كثير منها يعني متوقع مثلا مثل الملكه في
اشياء ثانيه بتفاجيء الواحد يعني شويه بس
انتم اصلا عندكم كم كبير من المعلومات كيف
يتم حصرها ودراستها عشان تطلعوا بهذه
القوائم طبعا هاي القوائم اللي احنا
بنعملها كل سنه خلال على السنين 12 لبعض
يعني وهي منحاول نفرج ايش الاتجاهات او
ايش الاشياء اللي الناس بحث عنها اكثر شيء
همم خلال السنه الماضيه في كل دوله من
انحاء العالم ومنطلع من حولنا نشوف ايش
الاشياء الجديده اللي طلعت هذه السنه يعني
خاصه ضد النظر عن الاشياء اللي كان متوقع
مثل همم
كويس على حق شفنا مثلا اهتمام جديد هذه
السنه وكان بشكل اكبر على فرق تحويل
العمله ما بين الجنيه المصري للدولار
الامريكي وهذا طبعا بنتيجه اللي هو انخفاض
سعر تحويل العمله في مصر همم فبالتالي همم
المواطنين في مصر طروا انهم يروحوا يفشوا
حتى يعرفوا الاسعار
ولا حط كمان في الفيديو اللي انتم عاملينه
همم او تعرف كل سنه عن سنه بيلاحظ بزياده
الاهتمام يمكن بموضوع الصحه النفسيه او
كيف انه زي ما انتم بتقولوا انه اغير او
اعثر على الشغف او همم اكون حياتي مثلا
تلقائيا اكثر او هذا هل البيض اللي
بتلاحظوا هذا الترند ماشي طبعا همم هذا
الشيء شفناه قاعد بيزيد وواتيرته بعد يعني
وحوالي اكثر من 65% من الاشخاص في الوطن
العربي سواء كان في مصر في الامارات
بشكل اكبر حتى معاد من الفرجي ال- ال-
النساء على الانترنت قاعدين بيفتشوا كيف
هم كمان يكونوا يتعلموا مهنه جديده او انه
يلاقوا شغل همم عن طريق الانترنت كمان همم
هذا طبعا سوف نتيجه اهتمام الوعي الناس
على الصحه النفسيه بعد خلال فتره ال- ال-
الكوففت والحجز اللي كان قاعد بيصرف
كل هذه الكلمات همم يعني صار عليها بحث
بزياده اعتقد خلال فتره كوفي وما بعد بس
انتم بتسووا هذه الاشياء بطريقه يعني هل
عندكم لانه كده مثلا جهاز بيحسب بالامور
ولا كيف بتصير همم
العديد من الخوارزميات اللي بتحاول تجمع
ايش هي العمليات البحث
المتشابهه من اكثر من مكان ومنحاول نشوف
ايش هي العمليات اللي بتطلع طبعا هذا احنا
بنعملها البحث لما نشوف المزيد من
المواطنين مثلا سعر تحويل العمله من
الجنيه للدولار بنحاول نشوف كيف نقدر
نجاوبهم بشكل اسرع بشكل ادق ونفرجيهم
معلومه بشكل محدثه بشكل اسرع وهذا طبعا
بيساعدنا نتجاوب بشكل همم سريع
المحادثات اللي بتصير في هذه الدول ياخذني
النقطه اللي هو انتم تكونوا تتكلموا عنها
سابقا انكم بتحاولوا ترفعوا من جوده
السيرتش العربي عشان يصير همم جوده الشرج
بالانجليزي كيف صار معكم هذا الموضوع اول
وصلتوا فيه طبعا احنا بنعمل تحديثات دوريه
على جوده الخدمه تبعتنا وهمم اسرعنا من
وتيره هذه التحديثات خلال السنين الاربعه
والخمسه الماضيه همم واحده من اجمل همم
الاشياء الجديده اللي هو اا انت هلا بتقدر
باستخدام عدسه جوجل عدسه جوجل عن طريق
تطبيق جوجل بتصوري او اي شيء بتفتح
الكاميرا عليها تتعرف على هو هذا
وبتفرجيكي منتجات مثله بتفرجيك النتيجه
هلا بدنا احنا نعرف اشياء الخطوه اللي
بعدها مثلا
او شيء معين او كان لونها اسود المباشر
انت لما تحكي بدي مثل بس بالابيض اه جوجل
قادر تعرف انت شو انك تقصد اللون بدك مثل
هذه اللبسه اللي موجوده نفتش لك وين
الاماكن اللي قريبه منك اللي بتفتش عادي
اللبسه ونجيب لك المعلومات بشكل اوضح وهذا
نفهم مش بس بالضبط همم الطلب تبعك بس حتى
اللغه والخصائص والموقع الجغرافي تبعك في
المنطقه العربيه كمان رائع لو جوجل بس
يتحول لانسان ويصير ماشي معي طول الوقت
بسوي لك في الاخر ان شاء الله هدفنا في
جوجل يكون همم موجودين لما اي حد يحتاج اي
مساعده في اي موجود من المعلومات اللي
ممكن تطلب منها
ان شاء الله تخيلت كده واحد ماشي جنبك همم
بتتحكموا في تجربه ثاني السوق البحث او
انتم همم المحرك الاول في البحث همم همم
بالضبط
ااا الاحدث ونطور من حالنا حتى نجاوب على
ايش الاشخاص بيحتاجوا في اي وقت بس كيف
بتتعاملوا الان مع دخول مو بس محرك بحث
جديد في المنافسه لا انه الان كل الدراسات
بتشير الى انه مثلا من الصاج مثل تيك توك
الناس بتدخل عليهم وبتستعملهم كم محركات
بحث ايضا زي ما انا حكيت لك احنا غالبا
نركز على قدرتنا احنا نفسنا نحاول نطور من
منتجاتنا ناخذ ايش الاشياء الجديده
المستخدمين بفضلوها بنحاول نخليتهم احسن
معلومات عن احدث واسرع في نفس الوقت
وبالعكس كل ما يكون في المنافسه في السوق
او في المنطقه معينه من المنتجات بيكون
احسن لانه هذا بيشجع همم همم توفير همم
تجربه استخدام احسن للمستخدم في الاخر
نكون ما عندك ناس بتتنافس الفائز الوحيد
هو المستخدم هذا هو شيء في الصوت
طبعا بس انتم يعني بتحرسوا على المقدمه
كمان في النهايه
حتى اجهزه
السؤال عنده
طريق انه نكون عندنا احدث واحسن واسرع
الاجوبه اللي هم ممكن يحتاجوها
بنشكرك على هذه اليوم اللي مشاركه
والمعلومات هذه عن ايش بحثوا الناس او ايش
كانت اهتماماتهم في 20 22 لما الواحد
بيرجع بيطالع فيها بيشوف قديش كانت السنه
مليانه بالاشياء ولي اهتمامات المختلفه
طبعا باشكرك كان معنا رئيس تسويق المنتجات
الاستهلاكيه في جوجل الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا
ان شاء الله في الخميس الونيس اجمل ايام
[موسيقى]